bonjour daniel viger bonjour bonjour
docteur daniel viger vous êtes médecin
il faut le rappeler
vous avez exercé dans la médecine
sportive longtemps également dans ce
qu'on peut appeler la médecine sociale
vous avez été médecin fonctionnaire ou
au conseil général
et puis vous voilà aujourd'hui donc
président de l'amdh or c'est un parcours
somme toute assez logique pour vous tout
à fait vous savez que suite au numerus
clausus dont on parle aujourd'hui je
suis le premier gène et ce numerus
clausus en 1971 eh bien il ya une
raréfaction des médecins et donc les
médecins apparemment aujourd'hui
deviennent des cumulards et j'en fais
partie
façon de voir les choses
alors l'homme d'or l'association
martiniquaise pour la promotion et
l'insertion de l'âge d'or
vous avez pris la présidence là depuis
quelques temps d'une association qui est
devenu une institution dans le paysage
sanitaire martiniquais de la santé
publique
tout à fait les universités étrangères
pour les sites et des canadiennes et
même des universités françaises sont
persuadés que nous sommes une université
et oui la mode a embrassé par ses
fondateurs
je veux citer le président michel viau
et dr yo yo qui a été le deuxième
président de l'amdh heures anthropologue
à la retraite aujourd'hui
et puis l'emblématique directeur je vais
parler de france rémy qui a fait valoir
ses droits à la retraite au mois de
juillet est bien là me doit un peu plus
et où tu sais oui d'activité aussi bien
dans le champ de la famille puisque nous
avons une école des parents des enfants
et des grands parents sur ma fille est
la fédération nationale des iut écoles
10 par an
nous avons aussi des prix la formation
de la préparation au départ à la
retraite donc vif succès avec même des
des croisières gérontologique
on va dire sur des paquebots mais
l'activité surtout la plus important
c'est la formation
je n'ai pas porté le catalogue mais à
l'occasion d'aller sur internet vous
allez voir le catalogue de formation
formation formation professionnelle
formation professionnelle des formations
médico-social et et juste pour donner un
point d'ancrage lame d'eau et
l'établissement à voir former la grande
majorité des directeurs des
établissements médico-sociaux d'aventis
n'y aura pas échappé aux préjugés
la dernière formation que nous avons
domiciliés continue je pèse mes mots
en partenariat avec l'une fall une fois
les centres de formation et qui exercent
en région parisienne cette unité delà
des héros jss
nous allons nous avons mis en place
depuis déjà sept huit mois en gros une
formation de mandataire judiciaire
on sait qu'une pénurie de cette
formation dans l'intérêt de tout ça
c'est de permettre des fois des chômeurs
à des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens de
ne pas partir parce que trouver un
logement sur la région parisienne
est-ce que berger prix des billets
d'avion ça coûte cher et le cloud office
est faux et je pense que c'est un tout
c'est l'âme de la part de tirer
aujourd'hui à plastronner en disant
voilà nous sommes ceux ci la me doyon
reconnu et donc c'est vrai que lambda
et à sa 28e et un conte gérontologique
des avant gardistes
on va y venir mais le type d'association
comme ça qui fait effectivement comme
j'ai dit dans la santé publique vous
l'aï dit le ministre social voire même
l'économique et social puisque à travers
la formation vous avez les moyens quand
comment comment vous parvenez parce
qu'on sait que beaucoup d'associations
notamment dans ce domaine ont des
difficultés comment vous vous arrivez à
à tenir la route je veux dire elle a
alors ça demande une gestion
pointilleuse premièrement sa demande la
présence de personnel polyvalent et
j'aime a répété qu'il n'y a pas de ces
supplémentaires pour des agents sa
demande l'engagement extraordinaire il
s'agit veut le reconnaître des bénévoles
si vous voyez le nombre de bénévoles qui
circulent autour de la autour de lames
d'eau je crois que c'est presque
exceptionnel et donc c'est surtout avec
un conseil d'administration évidemment
qui prison
et puis des présidents alors souvent
d'ailleurs tout le temps ce sont les
présidents médecin c'est par volonté de
de choisir si c'est parce qu'en réalité
le volet gériatrie aussi et gérontologie
la porter et docks
un médecin peut en parler mais tous
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait prendre la
place sans problème
alors effectivement ce sont des moyens
jeudi et parce que nous sommes une
association loi 1901 il n'est pas
question de faire de l'argent sur les
gens mais malheureusement on est obligé
de calculer le prix le plus juste quand
vous devez faire venir des intervenants
extérieurs il faut les payer alors très
peu de subventions des collectivités
c'est vrai mais bon moi je n'en veux à
personne
alors nous avons une activité
particulière avec la collectivité
territoriale de la martinique c'est une
activité qui date déjà de mémoire depuis
1991 92 dans le cadre d'une convention
c'est le suivi les familles d'accueil
dispositif
la télévision l'a montré encore hier
soir et avant-hier sa dispositif
intermédiaire qui permet à des personnes
de ne pas être placés ou encore hébergés
dans des établissements les gens mise en
retraite ou ehpad docteur daniel viger
nous sommes donc dans la semaine bleue
on va terminer avec les rencontres
gérontologie que vous avez tenus en fin
de semaine dernière mais une question
dans le cadre de cette semaine bleue une
préoccupation de nombreux seniors chez
nous en martinique se passe' allender
vous vous en préoccuper mais c'est le
manque de moyens de locomotion pour
beaucoup de personnes du troisième âge
de pointe de ce point de vue est ce que
vous pourriez intervenir pour une
meilleure organisation bons débuts sedan
alors les situations sont diverses d'une
commune à l'autre mais enfin voila c
c'est souvent ça remonte ça revient le
problème de moyens de locomotion pour
les personnes âgées mais d'une façon
plus large il faudrait aussi que les
deuxièmes transport à jouir voulait que
les décideurs une écoute plus attentive
des techniciens du domaine nous qui
avons la culture et surtout nous qui
nous rencontrons les personnes suivent
le diraient mes moyens de transport en
fait bon se passe coupet est de dire
qu'il ya des difficultés alors bien
heureusement le tcsp venus améliorer la
situation
parce que les personnages et le plus
souvent elles ne conduisent pas là et
dans leur poche quand elles sont trop
vagues et de vouloir conduire leur les
moyens qu'on peut pas mobiliser des
sociétés de transport la femme la
fameuse silver economy dont on nous
rebattait les oreilles il ya moins de
dix ans ça devait être géré avec quels
moyens et quel moyen mais nous sommes
prêts à réfléchir à un dispositif il y à
des associations
donc c'est un miroir aux alouettes
s'étaient même aimé le évidemment
derrière tout ça est vrai que tous aient
le pouvoir de l'argent
alors est-ce qu'on veut développer
est-ce qu'on veut développer un
dispositif spécifique
on va revenir la pression conjointe
rogie le président de la fédération
internationale des associations et clubs
de troisième âge
monsieur alain costes qualité ici qu'est
ce que le dit il dit la martinique du
vieillissement devrait être un
laboratoire et cela vaut à toi il serait
d'autant plus intéressant que les lames
d'or et pour lui
président de la fédération
internationale le premier laboratoire
qu'il connaît donc discute en apportant
des idées je ne dis pas que la mort a la
science infuse pour dire ce qu'il faut
faire mais il est manifeste que de la
même manière que nous demandons le
positionner ses as a service en certains
endroits afin de faciliter pascali
trajectoire vous n'allez pas demander à
une personne âgée de monter au pied de
la montagne pelée
donc il ya une réflexion à monter sur
quel circuit pour avait surnagé
quels moyens si vous mettez des bus avec
la première manche à 30 centimètres
alors que vous avez que ce sont des gens
qui le plus souvent de l'arthrose du
genou
ça sert à rien quand il faut des bus
adaptés avec le premier plancher qui
descend au ras des pâquerettes avec des
world forum qui sont adaptés et puis au
niveau de l'europe de l'urbanisme via un
aménagement aussi de la ville quand j'ai
de la vie je ne parle pas de fonds de
fonds seulement de la vie c'est à dire
tout le film avec un maillage
alors oui mais vous avez on la constate
on l'a connu des transports en quelques
pas qu'il fonctionnait
on va dire relativement bien par rapport
à l'époque ont elles connu les bombes là
tu m'as moi dans mon enfance j'ai connu
les bons mots qui partait en commune et
croyez moi il était à l'heure quand il
était à 11h55
et nous qui habitons ici à saint viaud
on savait que la buse de basse pas qu'il
passait au prochain à leur service et le
sujet n'est pas essentiel dans les
horaires des bus comme si c'est
important mais c'était de savoir si que
ceux ci ça peut s'organiser un service
est un fonds dédié service de transport
en commun des sadc revient aux personnes
âgées d'ali daei juste dans le cadre des
mardis de latrines que nous avons
instaurée au niveau de la collectivité
la collectivité a mis un système de bus
pour permettre donc on peut l'étendre à
l'infini pour toutes sortes d'activités
c'est possible alors il ya des moyens
rapidement l'accueil familial pour les
personnes âgées
adultes handicapés réalité perspective
c'était le thème des rencontres
gérontologique il ya peu de temps
pourrait résumer un petit peu ce qu'il
en est ressorti et comment vous
appréciez la situation de ce point de
vue là c'était l'occasion de confronter
des pratiques nous avions présents la
guyane saint martin marie galante la
réunion et trois départements français
de france métropolitaine et puis on
avait 15 participants avec la secrétaire
d'état à la santé des trinidad and
tobago qui venus voir le modèle pour
savoir s'il est exportable
car oui dès le modèle auquel le modèle
pas le modèle de la martinique
le modèle de l'accueil familial en
général l'accueil familial dispositif
souple on va dire même intime qui permet
à une personne âgée de sortir de son
domicile pour aller dans un autre
domicile et si j'avais eu une phrase a
donné à réfléchir à charger le métier à
domicile
cette phrase un générique
il s'agit pas du métier à mon domicile
c'est du machin à notre domicile
c'est à dire que demain matin monsieur k
aurige une maison suffisamment grand
nous trois et six personnages et nous
pourrions habiter chez du vote
merci daniel viger d'avoir participé à
ce sens qu'a dit bonne journée